the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
[Music]
club
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome to
the stage executive director of the St
Louis chess club Tony
rich thank you all and welcome to the
opening ceremony of the 2023 us
championship and US women's champ
Championship we're also very honored
tonight to be able to induct the US
Chess Hall of Fame inductees for the
class of 2023 tonight uh as the voice
overhead just said my name is Tony Rich
and I'm the executive director at the St
Louis chess club it's my privilege to
have been able to host and organize
every us championship and US Women's
Championship since 2009 right here in St
Louis and of course none of that would
be possible without the support of play
ERS fans Spectators donors staff vendors
and everybody who makes trust happen but
in particular genan rexing
field you know it's funny I think the US
championships are these events right now
are probably my second favorite event of
the year I like the junior championships
the girls junior the US senior
championships because I get to meet all
the players before they're really really
strong um the US championships and the
US Women's championships represent
present the Pinnacle of Chess in America
these are the very best players that our
country has produced and uh I think
we're all very proud so a round of
applause for all of the
[Applause]
players someone else that should have a
lot of pride in her work and in helping
grow chess nationally is Dr jeie Karen
sinkfield it's my pleasure to introduce
her now
[Applause]
Jeanie
welcome to St Louis I'm thinking it's
like 15 years ago my husband came up to
me with this small idea let's he could
start a chess club I mean how expensive
could that
be so since then the chess club and my
husband who I'm going to
introduce has done wonderful things
we've had I don't know how many how many
how many years have we had the uh
the the Chess Championship here 15 years
not bad for nothing but when we started
it was very little chess had not
blossomed for a long time in uh the US
so Rex and I got in this little
competition so I got the Boy Scouts to
prove chess's a mer badge and I just got
the number it's a little over 300,000
Scouts have earned
it and they and this is this is the best
part they have to play in a tournament
and they have to teach someone
else and then because Rex was doing all
this wonderful stuff of finding the best
players and bringing them to St
Louis I decided that I had to work on
the audience so we now have a little
booklet that you guys can get for free
it's now available in 13 languages and
it teaches kids
literacy so I'm a terrible chess
player but I can grow your
audience but I what I really want to do
is talk about Rex and his passion for
chess I mean think about this there's no
reason for St Louis to be the chess CLE
of the US and maybe the world
right and no one had a vision to think
about how could you do this not only at
the highest level but at the in between
level and growing and Growing Kids
across the country and across the world
so it's my honor to introduce the Goda
of American chess my loving husband
rexing
[Applause]
field
[Music]
you can keep playing the music that way
I don't have to
speak well I want to welcome all of the
players to St Louis also referred to as
the chess capital of the nation this is
always my favorite time of the year when
we have the best players in America
playing chess Jeanie and I are delighted
to host these prestigious and amazing
tournaments and speaking of amazing how
about this men
[Applause]
you as you as some of you probably know
soccer as we call it here in the
colonies is
native uh to St Louis only for the last
year but prior to that going back in the
60s and 70s s and long before that St
Louis was the soccer capital of the
United States and in fact in the 1960s
St Louis University they had a soccer
team there they still do but then they
were the national champion for 10 years
in a
row now this u a few weeks ago I both
myself and Carolyn Kendall who's one of
the new owners of the soccer team were
inducted into the St Louis Sports Hall
of Fame and I have to say it was an
honor for both of us to be inducted into
that
class
so I would first like to
recognize spectrum and Silverback
Studios my son Randy and Kevin Dew they
have very talented teams that create and
make the production and broadcast an
amazing
experience and uh we have of course our
incredible staff with joy Bray and Tony
Rich and all the folks at the World
Chess Hall of Fame they are the ones
that make all of this happen
um this year we have moved the new the
old chest Studios to a new location and
I think everyone will love the online
broadcast anchoring the broadcast are
people you're used to Grandmaster Yas
Sarah one women's Grandmaster Katarina
neova and Grandmaster Christian
[Applause]
Chilla so we get a broadcast team that
strong we believe it causes the players
to have to strive to reach that
level now on behalf of the chess club
and the board of directors the St Louis
Club remains committed to our mission of
creating a worldclass venue for players
from across the globe to enjoy and we
will do everything in our power to
continue to make the tangible meaningful
changes that Foster an equitable
environment and help the St Louis Club
be the safe and best place in the world
to play chess thank
[Applause]
you thank you Rex us chess is the
governing body for chess in America uh
the organization is responsible for
things like ratings for American players
for fielding the teams that go to the
olympiads for hosting things like the US
Open that actually qualifies into the US
Championship um in addition to that us
chess is the is the thought leader in
chess in America one of the things I
think I like most um in attending the
delegates meetings is just how
Grassroots the approach can be us chess
does an amazing job of really bringing
together volunteers and folks from
across the country starting chess clubs
running tournaments running programs in
schools um and one day maybe becoming
Grand Masters and playing right here in
St Louis uh the executive director of us
chess is Carol Meyer and Carol's been a
great partner in chess uh through the
years as we've worked these US
championships and it's my pleasure now
to introduce
Carol good evening everyone I I'd like
to add my welcome to everyone and
especially congratulate all the players
for qualifying for this year's
championships did you know that the the
modern US Championship is in its 67th in
instantiation and the Women's
Championship is in its 63rd I had no
idea that we had a Women's Championship
that long the St Louis chess club has
hosted the last 15 US championships
elevating The Prestige of these Premier
Events and you the players are the best
us chess has to offer and we're proud to
see you
here over the next two weeks we
celebrate that us chess and the St Louis
chess club do what we do best we are
committed to creating a welcoming and
safe environment for all be they one of
the top players or the Casual chess fan
since the Championships came to St Louis
in 2009 we have learned that we have
learned more than anything we want what
is best for the game and for the people
who make up our chess community and I'm
proud that us chess is able to partner
with the St Louis chess club as leaders
in the Chess
World The Hub of Chess in the United
States is St Louis now home to us chess
we're grateful to Dr Jeanie and Rex
singfield for their unprecedented
support for the game and its players and
on behalf of the US chess Community we
thank
you the team on the US on the on the
chess campus is unrivaled anywhere and I
would like to offer my thanks to Tony
Joy Shannon and Emily and others for
everything you do for the game and
to thank you and to all the all the
players may your moves be good this next
couple of weeks and I wish you only
success as you compete during the event
thank
[Applause]
you and as Carol said it really is a
village that uh produces all of these
things here in St Louis uh one of the
folks who helps make uh chess great in
St Louis is Emily alled and she's the
assistant curator at the World Chess
Hall of Fame
Emily hi so on behalf of the World Chess
Hall of Fame I'm happy to welcome you
all to the 2023 us Chess Hall of Fame
inductions through our mission we
celebrate the rich history and culture
of the game of chess we are currently
hosting two exhibitions exploring these
topics the first sound moves explores
how music has inspired chess players as
well as how the game has in influenced
musicians across genres the second TS
Elliott a game of chess explores how one
of Missouri's best known writers and
Poets explored the game in his Landmark
poem The Wasteland I hope you all will
have a chance to enjoy these exhibitions
while you're in St Louis um these would
not have been possible without the
generous support of Dr jeie Karen
sinkfield and Rex sinkfield who make all
of our shows possible um we are also
grateful to our wonderful staff for all
of the work that they do to create these
exhibitions every year the World Chess
Hall of Fame celebrates the players
writers and other figures whose actions
have changed the game of chess during
the US Chess Hall of Fame inductions
these have been held since 1986 and have
now been in St Louis for many years each
year the United States Chess Federation
recognitions committee selects
candidates for induction and the US
chess trust confirms the nominees we are
honored to recognize the achievements of
Lisa Lane William shankman and Yuri
Schulman as history is about to be made
at the Championships right here in St
Louis um seil weam manry the US chess
trust vice president for Scholastic
chess and the executive director of the
N National Scholastic chess foundation
will be conducting this year's
inductions please welcome seil to the
stage
[Applause]
good evening
everyone the usess Hall of Fame and
worldes Hall of Fame are both house in a
beautiful Museum located in the Central
West End of St
Louis the partnership between St Louis
and the US chess trust dates back to
prior to that the Hall of Fame had been
housed in New Windsor New York
Washington DC and Miami
Florida my fellow trustees would
wholeheartedly agree that both Halls of
Fame have found a permanent home here in
St Louis and we are grateful to Rex and
Genie singfield for having made it
happen in the audience today are three
other
trustees president
W Beatrice
Marinello Beatrice are you
there secretary Alexander
kerford
Alex and trustee Rex
[Applause]
singfield thank you for being
here as the Le off from the cross to the
Hall of Fame it is my pleasure and
privilege today to induct the class of
2023 to the usess Hall of Fame we have
three new
inductees our first induct is former US
Women's Champion Lisa
Lane Miss Lane was unfortunately not
able to join us
today her plaque reads as
follows Lisa Lane is a Pioneer in the
development of women's trust in the
United
States a late Comer to the game who only
started playing in her late teens Lane
made rapid progress and within two years
of learning the rules had earned the
title of expert and won the 1959 US
Women's
Championship she would go on to
represent the United States in two
women's inter zonals a women's
Olympiad and win another US Women's
Championship tying for First with jel
agressor in
1966 L's accomplishments attracted media
attention to the game came and she was
the first chess figure to appear on the
cover of Sports Illustrated in August of
1961 and so with the authority vested in
me I hereby induct Lisa Lane to the US
dress Hall of
[Applause]
Fame our next inductee is William
shinman who is being honored
posthumously
his flaque reads as
follows William shinkman ranks among the
greatest problem composers in chess
history he composed over 3500 problems
on a variety of themes in a career
stretching over six decades earning the
nickname The Wizard of Grand
Rapids shinman began his activity in the
Golden Age of problem solving in the
last half of the 19th
century when daily
newspapers all
carried all over the United States had
CH
columns these columns invariably
included composed problems to solve many
of them
shinkman besides being a giant in the
field of problem solving shinkman was
also influential in the development of
Chess
puzzles and so with the authority
invested in me I hereby conduct William
shinkman to the usess Hall of
[Applause]
Fame I almost fit on the
glass our third induct is Grandmaster
Yuri Schulman who is here with us today
his plaque reads as
follows Yuri Schulman's record in US
chess championships is notable for both
its excellence and
consistency shulan played in nine of
these events after moving to the United
States from his native Belarus where he
was national champion in
1994 and European Junior Champion the
following
year Schulman won the US Championship in
2008 finished second in 2006 2010 and
2011 died for third in 2005 and 2007
and shared forth in 2004 and
2012 his lifetime winning percentage of
61.5% in these events is among the best
ever Shan represented the United States
in two olympiads winning team Bronze in
2008 and in two World Team Championships
winning team silver in
2011 and so with the authority invested
in me
I hereby
induct Grandmaster Yuri
Schulman to the US Chess Hall of
[Applause]
Fame I would now like to invite
Grandmaster Schulman to the stage for
some words grandmas
shulan
thank you chenil thanks
everyone uh when I was told that I would
be delivering the speech today I thought
that what can I uh say something new to
you guys I cannot help to uh Sol the all
the conflicts in the world like you know
all the wars which are happening right
now and which we really feel sad about
um I canot definitely help to most of
you who are here like to become better
chess players since you are much better
than I have ever been though like shil
was talking for a while that I was
winning something um but then I was
thinking about like what is chess for us
um and uh um like I talked recently with
my friends and uh I realized we always
recall some wonderful moments we had in
chess and I would like to recall some uh
moments from my life and um hopefully
from some uh people who are present here
and and um some of us are present here
some of us are uh like my friends
support me and uh even my dad right now
I think is working and subbing me at the
chess club uh which we are running in
back in Chicago and uh I would like uh
also to recall people who are not with
us anymore and especially my mom who uh
when I was 5 years old uh she was walk
we were walking together to the
kindergarten and she notices that Yuri
somehow is not walking straight forward
she like what's happened to him and then
she noticed I try to move like a knight
or I tried to move like a bishop says to
my father who is by the way Grandmasters
and checkers he says probably
it's time to for him to switch the
activity and my dad started teaching me
how to play chess maybe he did it before
since I knew some P movement but um I
always remember how um as they also came
to some chess tournaments to the chess
uh y CH championships they came once and
I was not doing so well and still shil
that was one of the tournaments you
mentioned so I took second place there
so um and really and I'm thankful to my
friends as well not um who also
supported me various events um I'm also
recalling the
moment uh with like how we were studying
with Sam Shanklin who if he didn't give
you a book today yet uh then probably he
would at some point but but the funny
thing I was dreaming to get that book
because uh uh like me and Sam are
studying uh numerous about of rukan
games and constantly we're beating each
other in the puzzle white to play and
win with black pieces and and Sam it
looks like you really learned from that
so much how to play chess you're amazing
player and also amazing author now uh
and I also only learned from you how to
cook sushi and spring rolls but I still
remember it
uh I remember Ray Robson how you uh like
probably the only person who I had to
escape from studying chess because he
would wake up in the morning at 7 and
right away he would just uh drag me to
the chessboard and he would be really
plain for until probably midnight so the
longest time I ever played chess was
with Ray Robson um and um I remember
quickest move Wesley and me and kerina
at the chess Olympia
in R and Wesley made the quickest move
and he jumped into 50° water in uh
Arctic Ocean and the way he jumped out
was probably the most impressive thing I
ever seen in um so really really uh I
also uh met today Sam savian again who
played his uh first Chess Championship
uh when I played my last we played the
game he was still young and growing
talent and it was really amazing to to
see how he progressed after that and it
was very memorable game to play with Sam
um uh Rex and uh Jen you think I would
recall you as championships as the most
impressive no way my most impressive uh
uh memory with you was when you were
teaching me those Milky Way uh uh uh
galaxies yeah Rex really was taking time
to explain how beautiful they are and
where they are supposed to be and it it
was a great chess camp we had here at um
like when we prepared for turkey
Olympia I also would say that uh um I
would recall uh wonderful memories with
my uh coach is with Tamara uh gol who
just turned 80 years old this year and
remember how one of the first simal show
organized one of your student came over
and wanted to play with us with young
kids and I was so scared that I hid
under the table uh with her daughter so
we I don't know why we were so scared
but that was our uh first reaction and U
and I see some of uh my students here
who are present my friends who are
present here and who are supporting me
but I also would like to say that um not
only you want to be at the right place
and the right time but also you have to
be uh with the right person so it's
interesting when I was playing chess uh
and uh keep on accumulating all those t
titles um I didn't get awarded the Hall
of Fame uh induct but when my wife Tanya
uh came with me of course right away you
know she she was able to help me to get
inducted and we recalled
recently a joke of uh Michelle Obama and
Barack Obama when he was asked and uh
like they met one of their friends and
he asked oh you you were planing today
that guy right so like where would you
end up up today and she said I don't
know where I would uh end up uh where
would would you end up but I would be
still a wife of a president right so so
and definitely U we want to make sure
that yeah we really appreciate the
people who are with us and we really
appreciate our um memories in chess uh
and I I I really appreciate all the
experience and I I'm so happy to come
back here and uh also to see some uh uh
young players uh eternally young players
participating in addition to like at Le
like you a very young player but
definitely TV Arena Anna you absolutely
always eternally young you all always
will be playing this tournament very
happy to see you here and I really uh
feel how um much uh desire you have in
plain chess and how much enjoyment you
get it so guys I'm not going to delay
your uh desire to play your chess
tournament tomorrow just wish you good
luck tomorrow and have a wonderful us
championship and thanks to everyone to
for listening to me thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you
I still remember hanging out with Yuri
at the olympiads and watching him give a
signo there used to be a restaurant in
St Louis called heres
and come
on Tony just really looks like a serious
person but another amazing memory I had
is a competition um balloon blowing
competition at the istanb
olymp guys you would not you would need
to see it what guess who took first
second and third place in that
competition TF you might remember right
you you'll not cheat guys the when the
first balloon was blown off then second
and third places like we still very
clearly
[Music]
um we were still competing but Tony got
first second and third place guys so I'm
not going to talk anymore Tony thank you
sorry I had to
share well I'll keep my story a secret
now thank you y thanks now we're on to
the part of the evening where we do the
drawing of lots this is what the players
I think really care about it's the
reason they're here also because they're
contractually obligated to be here for
this
part uh so the drawing of lots is the
method by which we determine uh who will
play whom in which round so the both
tournaments are a round robin format
meaning everybody will play everybody in
their sections and they will draw a
pairing numbers one through 12 and that
will determine their pairing order to
assist me in drawing the pairing of lots
I have the Arbiters from the US
championship and US Women's Championship
starting off we have Frank Guadalupe
who's the chief Arbiter for us
Championship Frank if you could come on
up Chris bird who is the chief Arbiter
of the US Women's
Championship and Karen penck who is the
Deputy Arbiter for all of
[Applause]
it we will start with the US Women's
Champion ship field and to lead us off
we have the reigning US Women's Champion
Jennifer
[Applause]
you so Jennifer's going to draw a scarf
over here St Louis soccer oh I'm sorry
women's side I did this last time at the
junior Champs too guys doesn't get
better okay so Jennifer's gonna choose a
scarf uh St Louis
city that has a pairing number on it and
she has pairing number five
next up grandm Ina
[Applause]
[Music]
Crush Irena draws a scarf and chooses
pairing
number I didn't see number four next up
we have young Alice
Lee
Alice pixs her
scarf and she has pairing number
six International Master Carissa
[Applause]
[Music]
yip
Perry number
nine next up is international Master
Anna
zatonski and Anna chooses pairing number
two next up is go beum too Nova or be
him veum chooses pairing number
seven next is international Master Nazi
pidi Nazi picks a scarf and as pairing
number
one next up debuting her first US
Women's Championship atusa
[Applause]
porian and ausa draws 11 pairing number
11 next tat
abrahamian
[Music]
tatv has pairing number
eight next is St Louis's own Talia
cantes pairing number 10
next up is ashria
eswaran Parry number
12 and just to keep us honest last but
not least ruang
[Applause]
Yan and R Yang
has paing number
three okay we'll move on to the US
Championship field and we will start
with the reigning US champion
Grandmaster Fabiano
[Music]
caruana number 12 Bar number
12 get it out of the way for everybody
else you
know next up Wesley
[Music]
so Wesley
chooses flips it
over has pairing number
six another St Louis resident
Grandmaster livon
aronian
[Music]
Leon has pairing number
[Applause]
one another St Louis and I mean you
can't swing a dead cat without hitting a
grand master around here we have lenier
Dominguez
[Music]
par number
seven next up Sam
[Music]
Sean Sam as pairing number
nine
another St Louis in Grandmaster Ray
[Music]
Robson Ray has number
four next Jeffrey
[Music]
Jong
Jeffrey draws Parry number
two the author himself Grandmaster Sam
Shanklin Perry number
10 next up is Grandmaster Hans
nean
yes paing number
five another St Louis and Grandmaster
darus
[Music]
schz daro has pairing
number
eight
next up grandm ABI Mayo
[Music]
Mishra and obz pairing number
11 and last but of course not least
grandmas who won the US Open to qualify
for the US Championship this year Andrew
Tang
[Music]
sorry number seven thank you okay so now
I'm going to announce round one pairings
let me just grab those from our Arbiters
one
moment all right he asked if I can read
it and I said yes without looking so in
the US Championship round one we have
Grandmaster laavan aronian versus iano
Carana Jeffrey Jong versus ABI Mayo
Mishra Andrew Tang versus Sam Shanklin
Ray Robson versus Sam seian Hans nean
versus Darius SZ Wesley so versus lenier
Dominguez and in the US Women's
Championship field we have Nazi
against ashria esaron Anna zatonski
versus atusa porian ruangan versus Talia
cantes Arina Crush versus Carissa Yip
Jennifer Yu versus tatev abrahamian and
Alis Lee versus beum Tokyo Nova so those
are our pairings for round one don't
forget you can find all of the action at
uschess champs.com so we'll stream all
of the games there live uh I'm sorry on
a 30- minute delay uh we also stream our
commentary and you can find the
standings and the pairings you can see
our our bios for all of the players as
well it's a great place for information
about these folks so I mean the
Championships are the Pinnacle of Chess
in St Louis and it's really exciting to
have everybody back here now including
all of you I hope you're able to stay
around and enjoy some of the action
while the players compete across the
board make sure to tune in every day the
show will begin at 1:20 pm. at uschess
champs.com thank you all and have a
great
[Applause]
[Music]
night
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
[Music]
prohibited